Bà phía ông ngày 20 tăng ngăn sáo tại thường viên Mỹ đã trừng kiến sư dựa lột thời gian măng tên
quan Big Beautiful View Act của tổng thống đường nân trăm vượt qua bất đều tiên với tỉ lệ
nằm mốt bủ mi chính. Đây là một trong những ưu tiên là pháp lớn nhất của tổng thống
trăm trong những kỳ hiện tại bao gồm ra hạn các sạm thời tự năng anh yên không chơi
mấy bày. Tăng chỉ từ cuối phòng và nướng trình nợi bàn.
Fé cộng hoa phần định dựa lột sế tốt bệ tăng trường bảo vệ người đọc và cổ ăn ninh
tổng thống xa. Tổng thống trăm nhận mạnh nếu không thông qua Mỹ sẽ phải đối mạnh với mất tăng
thời lớn nhất trong lịch sử. Lánh đạo thường viện John Chôn gọi đây là cơ hội ngắn năm
có một để tạo dựa một nướng Mỹ mạnh mẽ và ăn quan hơn.
Tuy nhiên, Fé cần chủ và một số nghĩa sĩ cộng hoa phần đối, châu dăng dựa lột thiên
vị giới sâu, để gióa tất sảm ảm ảm ảm ảm ảnh sửa hội và khiến nợ công tăng mạnh.
Các tổ chuy đột lập ước tính bản dựa của thế làm tăng thêm bố nghiên tỉ đủ là Mỹ
sách về lâu sáng. Chỉ mạnh sảo X, tỉ phù lắm mơ s cũng lên tính chỉ trết, châu dăng dự lột sẽ
phá hội hàng chựa việc làm.
Sựa tìm bương vào dựa đảng trinh lợn sửa đổi trước khi bảo phía quay cùng đại thủ viện
nếu thung qua, phân bản dựa đức chuyển với hạv viện và chơ tổng thống tròn ký măng anh.